é eu fiz de conta a história dessa
menina que eu preparei pra vocês eu vou
descalçar os meus pés é pelo fato
problema porque porque eu quero como
educador e mediadora levar vocês
diante de todas as palestras que
acontecerão no grau de empatia e quando
a gente se coloca no lugar no outro a
gente deixa as nossas crenças
a gente deixa o nosso histórico de
aprendizagem
a gente deixa nossas metodologia e nós
deixamos as nossas teorias
quando nós somos pessoas com empatia
nós conseguimos ter a morosidade né
então o que falta para esse país mudar
idéias a gente vê o que existem pessoas
capazes pessoas que estão fazendo
acontecer e simplesmente uma coisa tão
simples que a morosidade e dentro dessa
morosidade nasce a flor que brota do
impossível
a gente vem da imagem
lowdon a lama a gente sai daí né
é como o que nós podemos imaginar o
pensar em nada a única coisa que a gente
vai ganhar um pé sujo né doenças
bactérias ou seja o que for
só que nós estamos ainda nada porque
dentro do molde lado da lama e eu
pesquisando para montar né
a palestra foi bastante porque eu
comecei a votar né na história da menina
e quanto essa história está impacto ando
e formando novos
programadores mediadores e essa flor
ela se chama flor de lótus e dentro
dessas pesquisas também instalar que tem
vários cientistas ainda não sabe como
isso acontece tem substâncias vegetais
têm várias informações mas o como que
acontece ea história dessa menina é como
a cor de uma essa menina nasceu em um
bairro de periferia evoluiu foi parar na
favela de heliópolis
dentro dessa trajetória ela passou por
exclusões
às opôs fome e olha a fome e dói e pensa
que a fome que dói é igual ao de um
indivíduo para o outro não é igual
quantas vezes a mãe teve que da água pra
ir dormir porque estava conforme a essa
família também ela trabalhou de
panfletar no farol de entregar panfleto
ea coisa mais sensacional é que na hora
de ser selecionada nesse farol para você
ser aceita
pra ser escolhida terá que ficar pulando
escolheu escolheu e tinha mais meninas e
meninos nas mesmas condições
só que essa menina tinha um sonho e esse
sonho era marcado num caderno
então ela marcava eu quero ser isso
quero fazer aquilo
quero conquistar outras coisas e ela
olhava pra lama e não via nada e ela
chegou aos 20 anos de idade dela
e continuou vendo nada o que ela
encontrava era a luz apagada sem água em
casa a então os pais não trabalhava e
era tudo vagabundo não o pai começou a
fazer bico
entregava descarregar um caminhão de
cana aqui do lado da sua casa tinha um
depósito de cana o dia todo para ganhar
10 reais
só que ele sempre falava pra esse
caminho
nós temos que conquistar as coisas
nós não podemos nos fazer de coitado
para te e aquilo ficou gravado
só que essa menina também era muito
terrível e o que mais marcou foi o
preconceito dentro da família porque o
seu pai era negro e sua mãe branca
então dentro da própria família tinha a
questão do preconceito racial
se os prêmios então quando se fazia o
leite para dar pra todo mundo pra um era
leite para o outro pra nós acrescentava
água o que mais uma com essa menina e
toda essa trajetória foi que quando ela
ia para a escola casa de mandela e não
tinha nada pra comer então tinha uma
vídeo locadora na videolocadora dava
pirulito e chegava lá elas pediam um
pirulito moço da vila saiu contente e
tinha uma tia do cachorro quente e essa
tia do cachorro quente sempre dava um
cachorro-quente elas dividiam em três
pedaços de iam para a escola e o sonho é
assim o sonho ele surge ele não escolhe
a sua condição social pela escola se
você está na lama ele não escolhe se
você está se você é rico se você fosse
você pobre
o sonho existe para nos incentivar
para ter esperança né então o sonho ele
não é sementes que eles vão escolher
onde ele vai ser germinado eles caem e
essa menina não deixou a exclusão que a
fome que obtive mesmo a fizesse de
existir
então quando ela leu o caderno lá ela
falou poxa vida já passou seguinte
continua mesmo não saiu de nada e aí
foram falando pra ela de informações e
dentro dessa trajetória de integrar
pleito
ela foi aprendendo que era políticas
públicas
ela foi aprendendo a se conhecer
ela foi aprendendo até conscientização o
porquê estamos nessa condição porque a
nossa família passa por isso
ae a sociedade ruim né é uma questão
social é uma questão nossa que nós não
fazemos nada vai para frente o que é o
que acontece
e ela foi se deparando e dentro disso
ela aprendeu a fazer projetos sociais
ela aprendeu política não é politicagem
ter politizado entender como foi
colocado muito aqui não existir ter
prazer participar federativo
então ela e não para um determinado a
mudar
ela viu um jornal neste jornal estava
uma de uma faculdade ela falou vou
tentar prestar o vestibular passou a
faculdade paga
como que eu vou fazer pra encostar sem
trabalho sem nada tudo um caso de ponta
cabeça
então ela foi conversar com a reitoria
não sabia falar direito
eu falava na malandragem que vocabulário
tinha e conseguiu a vaga
segundo essa faculdade ela se sente um
peixe fora d'água o que eu estou fazendo
aqui
essa não é a realidade mas a gente sair
lembra o seu sonho na escola onde ele
vai ser determinado e ela persistiu e aí
essa menina que fala irmã dulce passe de
jô também sabe falar de paulo freire
ballón e gota e foi aprendendo o tema
conhecimento
não é a fome não é a roupa que te faz
feliz ser transformador é o conhe
cimento então nenhuma dessas condições o
impediram de eu ser o que eu sou hoje né
de ter prazer de estar na frente de
tantas pessoas de poder contar a
história a minha história a onde o
futuro que me esperava ou era eu casar
com um traficante ou era ter uma penca
de filhos e viver nas mesmas condições
de onde eu saí e isso se chama né que a
gente tem o costume de falar dentro da
psicologia que nós temos que ter essa
autonomia né como foi colocada essa
mudança acontece primeiro dentro de você
mas como o cara vai acontecer dentro de
você
se você não consegue nada se você olha
no que não tem nada aí que vem os
transformadores
a tia do cachorro quente foi uma
transformadora a diretora que deu um
passeio de escola que fez essa menina
mudar todo o comportamento dela foi uma
transformadora
esse primeiro local que se chama urna
foi um meio de transformação porque foi
lá que ela começou a prender de
políticas públicas
foi lá que ela começou a prender o
direito da juventude
foi lá que ela começou a prender do
direito da mulher foi lá que ela começou
a ver a educação infantil onde que
começa tudo
foi lá que ela tem ela aprendeu sobre
medidas protetivas sobre abrigamento de
medidas socioeducativas
então foi aprendendo foi criano
conhecimento e chegou uma hora que ela
passou por todas esses locais e foi
deixando o que aprendia o que construí a
minha fala não pode ficar ao fim
cara eu conseguir o dentro da periferia
a gente muitas pessoas têm a informação
como eu coloquei aqui é sobre um projeto
social
vamos dar sua alimentação a casa mais
gostam é de roupa bazar né
alguns barzinhos gente faz uma
arrecadação e o conhecimento de verdade
ea informação para que esse menino ele
vai ficar na idade dos 20 e 30 anos
ontem quando ele tem 14 anos ele é
bonitinho depois com 16 17 que vai
querer dar cesta básica
quem vai querer dar comida e não é dar
enfunar e como que a gente ensina como o
conhecimento porque isso ninguém tira da
gente então é esse projeto tem um
significado muito grande porque é onde
nós estamos conseguindo colocar essa
ideia é essa mediação por isso que lá
dentro todos nós somos educadores e aí
dentro dessas atividades com as crianças
a gente faz jogos brincadeiras são
crianças
temos que ele é resgatar a infância que
muitas vezes é perdida e todo mundo
também pensar não tem mais jeito esses
adolescentes nunca sabem nada com nada
mas quais são os modelos que eles estão
tendo essa gente ver ondas e muitas e
marcou muitas vezes são paulo
muitas usam cara de crianças
principalmente negras ainda até costumo
falar porque é verdade catar lentas para
ganhar dinheiro e projetos sociais salva
vidas salvou a minha então e como foi
colocado se pessoas boas tem que abrir a
boca pra falar tem que abrir a boca pra
questionar e falar que tá errado então
dentro disso vêm surgindo da gente
transformar essa lama porque quando a
gente entra realmente uma pousada é de
terra é de lama mas com riquezas e tem
muitas flores de lótus ali e precisam
subir para a superfície para ser
visíveis em coisas escondidas sem
visibilidade então o pessoal de
periferia não quer seu dinheiro
esta reconhecido como o bispo também
colocou quando a gente pinta a carroça
a gente se torna me diga transforma esta
realidade e é dentro dessa realidade que
a gente consegue se transformar e como
isso acontece
contagiando outras pessoas vêm outras
pessoas com a mesma idéia se
transformando é através de estudo é
através de informação que a gente
consegue fazer essa transformação e ea
criança sempre vem com alegria mesmo né
mas nem toda essa alegria ela vai se
transformar em um adulto e ela também se
transforma em uma multiplicadora que ela
multiplica seus familiares ela
multiplica a sua comunidade
então ela é uma transformadora de si e
do seu meio e como que nós fazemos isso
vamos levar ele para entender o que é o
seminário da criança e do adolescente o
que é o ecca o que é política pública
porque você está aqui agora você pode
por uma faculdade tem condição de
conquistar ela e então dentro dessa
perspectiva desse pensamento nós
começamos a participar dos movimentos na
cidade porque a cidade funciona desse
jeito porque é a comunidade e dessa
forma é porque não adianta você
transformar um só
a gente quer transformar realidades e
para transformar a gente tem que
conscientiza aí muitos falam que é toda
essa palavra dada ea utopia não é só que
precisamos de pessoas responsáveis
nós precisamos de um modelo que também
acredita em nós não queremos opressores
para que fazendo mas não fazemos
temos de pessoas que realmente tenha
empatia pelo que muitos fazem doação
a descarga de consciência não vai
supervisionar não vai ver o que está
acontecendo onde está sendo aplicado o
como então nem faça continue nesse tem
fundamento são da época a gente aí
aquele que tava oprimido e teve um pouco
mais de conhecimento
ele tem que ser transformador mo moldar
o ambiente e onde ele está inserido e aí
são as nossas atividades onde a gente
participa de várias ações
então até a polêmica nada não redução da
maioridade penal mas porque como
entender ainda não é só um coitadinho só
isso não tem consequência as coisas já
existe então é compreender e levar o
entendimento e depois o sujeito com o
enredo eles quando o seu caminho
então nem falar que o caminho mais sete
caminho b é o mais correto não é mediar
e deixar ele escolher ele ser
protagonista
aí sim a gente vai começar a formar
cidadãos conscientes e transformadoras
essa atividade foi três anos antes e nós
perguntamos para as crianças o que elas
criam sei
elas informaram que queriam as meninas
queriam casar e ter filhos crianças e
cantora de funk
alguns mineiros queriam ser traficantes
é a realidade
alguns se espanta falou o modelo que tem
traficante dentro de uma comunidade o
herói do modelo 3 que o universitário
quando vai pra dentro das comunidades
eles levam outros modelos outras
possibilidades e aí depois que nós
fizemos novamente atividade saiu
pedagoga bióloga saiu policial
saiu boiadeiro e isso só me dá mais gás
na verdade isso que aconteceu aqui é uma
alavanca para mim porque tem pessoas com
a mesma idéia tem pessoas fazendo coisas
diferentes pessoas acreditando no outro
justa tem pessoas como humanização a
melhor organização é quando você
transfere o seu conhecimento para o
outro e da liberdade de ele escolher e
ser crítico diante da sociedade essa é a
maior liberdade existe mas para isso
acontecer
sozinha a família não faz nada têm
outros transformadores tem outras
pessoas que compartilham da mesma idéia
e assim a gente vai criando força e essa
turma contorno de transformadores
então o lobby a lama nada mais é que a
exclusão qualquer tipo de exclusão
o nosso sonho eo sonho que eu falei
tanto a esperança
o impossível
as coisas impossíveis transformadores
não precisa ser dentro do povo nada pode
ser com seu vizinho seu desenho montar
legal cara te ver o que tá até alguma
coisa mas tem como auxiliar tem quem tem
como ajudar
às vezes está do nosso lado e nós não
conseguimos ver né não conseguimos
impacto a impactar o outro e é isso que
eu deixo de pensar no negócio aqui já
está a falar a gente e tem eu amo paulo
freire né quando eu conheci o conheci
ele na faculdade fui entender que é
explicada
quem fala desse negócio de transformador
a morosidade liberdade e o que ele fala
é possível fim é possível uma porque eu
vivenciei é possível porque nós estamos
colocando em prática essa frase dele
movimenta muito
sou eu o mundo não é está sem meu papel
histórico não é só o de constatar o que
ocorre
mas também pôde investir como sujeito de
ocorrências seja sujeito de o currículo
seja transformadora estejam a diferença
dentro do nosso país da nossa política
sejam felizes em ter não existentes
porque existe néca placa existe e ainda
tem a sua contribuição
vamos ser e pra ser nós temos que fazer
temos que acreditar temos que investir
ea maior riqueza é levar o outro a sua
liberdade e nós podemos fazer isso
obrigado